بعد ان كان الحل اصبح اليوم المشكله من هو
طباخ بوتين ومؤسس فاجنر كان راس الحرب
الروسيه في خطوط المواجهه الاماميه
باوكرانيا وقد يتحول لوحش مطارده فرئيس
مجموعه فاجنريفي يعيش اسوا ايامه وهو معرض
للاغتيال او الاقصاء في اي لحظه بحسب
معلومات استخباراتيه لصحيفه تايمز
البريطانيه ووصف معارضون روس بريجوجين
بقرد يحمل قنبله يدويه اي يمكن توقع اي
شيء منه ما تكاثر اعدائه واضافوا ان مؤسسه
يفتقد لاي مكان امن في روسيا مرجحين ان
حياته باتت في خطر بعد تحوله من حل لاي
مشكله بالنسبه للكرملين وكانت خلافات
بريكوجين تصاعدت خلال الاسبوعين الاخيرين
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ووصلت لحد اتهامها
بالخيانه وصناعه المزيد من الاعداء ممن
ينتظرونك ومنه ايضا الصحيفه اشارت الى انه
بينما ينشغل بوتين بمعارك اوكرانيا قام
رئيس مرتزقه فاغنر بفتح جبهه اخرى ضد
قيادات في الجيش الروسي حيث نشر صورا
مروعه لجثث 30 عنصرا من مقاتليه مرجعا سبب
موتهم لشح القذائف وحرمانهم من الذخيره
بتصرف مقصود من قاده الجيش والدفاع
الروسيه ودائما وفقا الاتهامات بريكوتين
[موسيقى]